frappes qui ont touché la centrale
nucléaire de zappos leeja en ukraine une
centrale aux mains des russes théâtre de
nombreux combats ces derniers jours
ukrainiens et russes s'accusent
mutuellement d'être à l'origine de ces
tirs la situation à sa politique a fait
l'objet d'une réunion d'urgence du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu ce jeudi
les précisions de notre correspondante à
new york fanny chauvin
face à la menace d'une catastrophe
nucléaire le ton est très vite monté
entre les diplomates pour l'ambassadeur
britannique il faut appeler un chat un
chat sans l'invasion de l'ukraine par la
russie et bien il n'y aurait pas de
menace nucléaire
l'ambassadeur russe a quant à lui a
dénoncé le tissu de mensonges des
occidentaux les occidentaux qui accusent
une nouvelle fois moscou d'être
responsable des frappes autour de la
centrale de zaporijia mais le véritable
enjeu de cette réunion c'était bien la
question de l'envoi d'experts de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique pour inspecter la centrale la
centrale de zaporijia qui se retrouve au
milieu d'un champ de bataille déjà un
plusieurs infrastructures ont été
endommagés et un réacteur est arrêté
l'heure est donc grave a averti le
directeur de l' agence et même s'il n'ya
pas un de danger immédiat et bien la
situation pourrait changer à tout moment
lors de cette réunion à kiev a proposé
de créer une zone démilitarisée autour
de la centrale une proposition soutenue
par le secrétaire général de l'onu
antonio guterres s est aussi par les
états unis mais ces derniers jours on
assiste plutôt à une escalade militaire
autour de la centrale
la communauté internationale qui se
retrouve une nouvelle fois impuissante
dans ce conflit qui dure depuis près de
six mois
l'ancien conseiller à la c